hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures for
details just keep trickling out and with
the stakes so high after infinity war
literally any tiny clue could have
massive implications and potentially
spoiler warning before I go further but
in this case it's what appears to be a
leaked set photo of Gwyneth Paltrow as
Pepper Potts we're in a suit of Iron Man
style armor of her own the hell is going
on we got you covered
because when it comes to Marvel news
this channel loves makin mashenka is out
of Bucky dust so let's break down this
confusing social media post with another
new rockstars
tweet down okay we're talking about this
image of Gwyneth Paltrow's Pepper Potts
in front of a green screen wearing some
kind of new armor with a purplish bluish
color now this probably wasn't a selfie
posted by Gwyneth Paltrow herself should
be sued to death but it does appear to
be a legitimate photo not photoshopped
or anything I just out Paltrow would be
allowed to take selfies like this the
sets for these Avengers movies are
pretty locked down even for top-level
talent to me this looks more like the
kind of photo the hair or makeup or
costume departments might take to make
sure the characters look stays
consistency in the scene or take to take
and this photo also seems legit based on
other leaks we've seen one was a photo
that Paltrow did post herself on an
instagram story last year showing
herself and prep as Pepper Potts as her
body was wrapped up in a motion capture
suit now Paltrow has confirmed that
Pepper Potts did survive thanasis snap
and she even has gone as far as to hint
that of interest for it could be said
after a time John saying things like 10
years later and possibly having a kid
with Tony and this mocap suit suggested
that she wouldn't just appear in
Avengers 4 in a standard live-action
role but one augmented with some visual
effects then even more recently there
were some leaked designs of Avengers
toys one of which featured Iron Man
paired up with a female armor suit
purple and white colored I know it's
kind of dumb that we're analyzing toys
for clues for this movie but I've said
it before the answers are in the toys
people what are you hiding really the
reason this seems legit is the fact that
Pepper armor actually has precedent in
the Marvel Comics in 2009 mat fractions
run of the invincible Iron Man featured
Tony Stark designing a custom Iron Man
suit for Pepper Potts referred to as the
rescue armor Pepper don's this armor
under the name rescue and saves people
in emergency scenarios the rescue armor
is pretty much a standard Iron Man suit
none of the bells and whistles that
war machine or Iron Man's later suits
featured but the question is why does
pepper need this armor what's she gonna
use it for and if some of her scenes
will be shot with Paltrow in a mocap
suit why does she also need practical
costume armor the first theory is that
she could use this armor to rescue Tony
remember Tony and nebula were left on
Titan at the end of infinity war though
they did have the ship that nebula used
to get to Titan plus the Milano that the
Guardians used to get there it's just
not clear what state those ships are in
but really I just don't see why Pepper
Potts would need to spearhead that
effort rescue Tony far more qualified
galaxy travelers including Thor whose
fancy Stormbreaker battle axe contains
the power of the Bifrost allowing him to
flusche wherever the hell he wants
they'd be way more useful in helping
Tony get back to earth but a second
theory is a bit darker if the
interpretation of Paltrow's ten years
later time jump quote is correct what
kind of future will these characters be
living in think about it if half the
world population suddenly vanished
that'd be devastating you should check
out the HBO series the leftovers that
features the aftermath of a similar
rapture style event but in that case
only 2% of the population departed and
even then society we crazy the Erie Post
post-credits scene of ant-man in the
wasp with the emergency broadcast
blaring from the TV over the empty house
that was just the beginning the world is
probably gonna look a lot more like when
Nick Fury saw that helicopter crashing
the building chaos I'm not gonna go into
it but you do not want to flip a coin
for every person currently keeping
society intact air traffic controllers
people operating nuclear submarines that
little Dutch boy with his finger in the
whoa I'm not gonna say that word we are
talking about literal post-apocalyptic
times 28 days later post-apocalyptic I
am legend post-apocalyptic maybe Tony
Stark will have designed this new suit
for Pepper Potts as a form of regular
body armor that she wears every day to
protect her from the roving bands and
mutant zombies of this hellish future
hopefully also designed a toddler size
mark 85 for a little Morgan stop her
named TBD another theory for peppers
armor incorporates the more fantastical
directions that we predicted Avengers 4
could go specifically the possibility
that the movie could explore time-travel
and/or alternate timelines and alternate
realities and the comics Pepper takes on
the rescue armor after Tony Stark
actually goes in hiding there's a secret
invasion storyline in which some of the
Avengers are discovered to be scroll
shape-shifter imposters and Tony gets
blamed for it so he wipes his super
database and goes underground so pepper
essentially fills in in Tony's absence
as rescue now in this affinity war
timeline Tony was one of the lucky ones
who didn't vanish but maybe in the
avengers quantum Medellin and Avengers 4
we could see a new parallel timeline in
which history played out a bit
differently
like maybe in one of these timelines
Tony Stark didn't make it back through
the portal when tossing the nuke through
it or maybe got caught under sokovia
when Ultron dropped it or cap decided to
actually smash his face in Civil War or
maybe Tony just tripped and fell off a
building when trying to lecture Peter
Parker in homecoming look Tony's had a
lot of close calls and maybe just one of
them could have gone another way kicking
into motion a whole backup protocol in
which Pepper Potts and her mourning has
to carry on his legacy and the idea of
multiple parallel timelines with
alternate futures could also explain my
Paltrow had a practical costume armor in
this photo but a full goofy mocap
unitard in the other photo like maybe
there's yet another reality where she
takes on a different form entirely like
is she hold ooh that would know it bit
off a lot of fans if they did it that
way anyway comment down below with what
you think the story behind Pepper Potts
new armor will be and follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at yeah boss and
subscribe to me rock stars for tweet
downs and toy downs cake downs wait a
minute that's not a green screen behind
Paltrow oh my god Ruffalo We Need to
Talk